when you're writing poetry are you
writing to express your experiences or
do you write to inspire other people
no I write to to try to say what I see
what I've seen and of course I hope that
it's inspirational when you were right a
phenomenal woman
did you realize how many millions of
women would be inspired by that no I
didn't realize any of that I just said
just do the best I can
you may write me down in history with
your bitter twisted line you may tribe
me in the very dirt but still like dust
around does my sassiness upset you why
are you beset with gloom
just because I walked as if I have oil
wells pumping in my living room
just like moons and like funds with the
certainty of tides just like hope
springing high till I buy did you want
to see me broken bowed head and lowered
eyes shoulders falling down like
teardrop we can buy my soul soul crying
does my sassiness upset you don't take
it too hard just cuz I laugh as if I
have gold mines digging in my own
backyard you can shoot me with your
words you can cut me with your lies you
can kill me with your hatefulness but
just like life
all right there's my sexiness offend you
does it come as a surprise that I dance
as if I have diamonds at the meeting of
my thighs
out of the huts of history's shame I
ride up from a past rooted in pain I
ride a black ocean leaping and wide
Welling and swelling and bearing in the
time leaving behind nights of terror and
fear I rise into a daybreak miraculously
clear I ride bringing the gifts that my
ancestors gave I am the hope and the
dream of the slave and so you just
watched two amazing clips from Maya
Angelou take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]